vamos a imaginar que tenemos una
situación donde está un vector y este
vector es igual es un vector velocidad
igual a 5 metros sobre segundo y se
dirige hacia la derecha recordemos que
con vectores siempre tenemos que indicar
la dirección aquí mi pregunta es qué tan
lejos ha viajado o se ha desplazado este
objeto que viaja a esta velocidad
después de 5 segundos
vamos a hacer una gráfica tenemos en
este eje la magnitud del vector
velocidad estas líneas dobles a los
lados del vector velocidad indican que
solo la magnitud aquí no estoy viendo la
dirección y en este otro eje vamos a
tener el tiempo entonces este vector va
a una velocidad constante aquí vamos a
poner 1 2 3 4 5 5 metros por segundo en
el eje de la magnitud de la velocidad y
en el tiempo es 1 2 3 4 5 aquí más o
menos son los 5 segundos y nuestro
vector lo vamos a graficar de esta
manera
es una velocidad constante no va
cambiando se mantiene al mismo nivel y
en el momento en el que llega a los
cinco segundos marcamos este punto bueno
para responder a nuestra pregunta
podemos verlo de dos maneras ya vimos
gráficamente cómo quedaría y si queremos
analizar usando ecuaciones tenemos que
usemos un color más llamativo nuestro
vector velocidad va a ser igual al
vector desplazamiento entre el cambio en
el tiempo esta delta este triangulito
indica el cambio en el tiempo aquí lo
que nos interesa saber es el
desplazamiento así que vamos a despejar
lo de la fórmula para despejar lo de la
fórmula tenemos que multiplicar ambos
lados de la igualdad por el cambio en el
tiempo y nos va a quedar que este
desplazamiento es igual al cambio en el
tiempo para el vector velocidad y ahora
con los datos que tenemos tenemos
nuestra velocidad y nuestro tiempo es de
5 segundos lo sustituimos en la fórmula
por la velocidad que cinco metros por
segundo las unidades y los segundos se
van 5 por 5 25 eso es igual a 25 metros
mi desplazamiento mi desplazamiento es
de 25 metros y aquí hay que darse cuenta
de que esta cantidad es exactamente el
área que hay bajo esta línea de la
magnitud de la velocidad esto es un
cuadrado de altura 5 base 55 x 5 25
ese es el área así que el área bajo la
curva es lo mismo que lo que encontramos
para el desplazamiento al menos en la
parte de la magnitud si ven las unidades
también coinciden ahora veamos otro
ejemplo en donde la velocidad va a estar
cambiando no va a ser constante ahora
vamos a tener una velocidad que va a
estar aumentando se va a estar
acelerando entonces vamos a tener una
aceleración que es un vector que va a
ser igual a 1 metro por segundo al
cuadrado y también vamos a determinar va
a definir que la magnitud de nuestra
velocidad inicial
en este otro ejemplo va a ser igual a 0
y ahora cómo va a ser la gráfica de este
otro ejemplo en donde la velocidad va a
estar aumentando a un metro por segundo
cada segundo vamos a hacer esta otra
gráfica tengo mi eje de la magnitud de
la velocidad como en el caso anterior
tengo aquí mi eje del tiempo las
unidades del eje de la magnitud de la
velocidad son metros por segundo y las
unidades del eje del tiempo son segundos
y aquí hacemos nuestras divisiones en el
eje de la magnitud de la velocidad
y también aquí en el eje del tiempo
qué está pasando aquí bueno si
comenzamos con una velocidad inicial de
0 en el tiempo cero vamos a estar en
esta sección en el punto de origen si
pasa a un segundo tenemos la aceleración
de un metro por segundo así que en ese
primer segundo mi aceleración será de un
metro por segundo y aquí va a estar mi
velocidad cuando transcurre otro segundo
la velocidad se habrá incrementado otro
metro por segundo así que en el segundo
segundo tendremos dos metros por segundo
en el tercer segundo se habrá
incrementado otro metro por segundo la
velocidad así que voy a estar teniendo
este tipo de gráfica se va a estar
distribuyendo de esta manera
y nos damos cuenta que la inclinación de
esta línea viene siendo la aceleración
si ustedes recuerdan lo que es la
inclinación o la pendiente de una línea
si lo vieron en sus clases de álgebra
aquí se podrán dar cuenta que la
aceleración si vemos su definición
es el cambio en la velocidad
/ el cambio en el tiempo si lo vemos
aquí en la gráfica vemos que esta parte
es el cambio en el tiempo del tate y
esta parte de aquí arriba es el cambio
en la velocidad del tav de mi vector
velocidad por lo tanto está pendiente es
mi aceleración mi directora aceleración
y si vemos nuestra aceleración es
constante es una línea recta y no es una
curva como podemos ver en la gráfica
ahora quiero imaginar una situación en
la que mi aceleración siga siendo igual
a un metro por segundo al cuadrado pero
quiero saber después de que pasaron
cinco segundos cuál fue la distancia
recorrida el ejemplo anterior es sobre
velocidad constante en este caso mi
velocidad no es constante pero sí lo es
mi aceleración así que en este caso cuál
va a ser la distancia recorrida vamos a
asumir que comenzamos desde cero y vamos
a asumir que estamos aumentando un metro
por segundo cada segundo durante cinco
segundos entonces tenemos aquí un
segundo dos segundos tres
24 segundos y 5 segundos 5 segundos
voy a estar en este punto de mi gráfica
y aquí sabré que habrán pasado debido a
la aceleración constante tengo una
velocidad de 5 metros por segundo
después de 5 segundos pero yo quiero
conocer la distancia el desplazamiento
que fue recorrido durante este tiempo
visualmente podríamos estar dibujando
algunos rectángulos una figura cuya área
sea fácil de calcular y así calcular el
área de cada una de estas secciones e
irla sumando para tener un aproximado
del área total bajo la curva de esta
pendiente o de este triángulo pero vemos
que están quedando estos huecos que
están bastante grandes
bueno que otra cosa podemos hacer para
que no nos queden estos huecos
una cosa que se me ocurre es en lugar de
tener nuestros rectángulos de un segundo
en la base pues podríamos estarlos
graficando con una base de medio segundo
así serían menos anchos y de esta manera
los huecos quedarían un poquito más
pequeños
pues no serviría si no conociéramos la
fórmula para calcular el área de un
triángulo en este caso es bastante
sencillo así que nos podemos ahorrar
estos pasos de dibujar estos rectángulos
y calcular el área de cada uno y después
sumar la
y como ya vimos que este es un triángulo
recordemos cuál es la fórmula para
calcular el área de un triángulo
el área de un triángulo
es igual a la mitad de la base por la
altura está h indica la altura conocemos
estos valores eso es igual a un medio de
la base 5 segundos
por la altura que es de 5 metros por
segundo se van en estos segundos 5 por 5
25 esto lo divido entre 2 y me queda que
es igual a 12.5 metros
y este es el desplazamiento o lo que es
lo mismo el área de este triángulo que
tiene una base de 5 segundos y una
altura de 5 metros por segundo
aquí hay un par de cosas interesantes
primero que ustedes no se olviden de
recordar que el área bajo la curva que
resulta de graficar la velocidad con
respecto al tiempo va a ser la distancia
o el desplazamiento recorrido durante
ese tiempo y que la pendiente de dicha
curva va a ser la aceleración del objeto
en cuestión cuando tenemos una velocidad
constante pues no tenemos aceleración
por lo que vemos aquí nuestra pendiente
es de 0 y la magnitud de la aceleración
también va a ser 0 en este caso tenemos
una aceleración constante por lo que la
pendiente va a ser esta aceleración en
este caso la determinamos como 1 la
aceleración o la pendiente es igual a 1
en este caso sí
era una aceleración variable y la
velocidad también cambiará entonces esto
no sería una línea recta sería una curva
o tendría una forma diferente y ahí
sería un poquito más complicado calcular
el área bajo esa curva pero de todas
maneras el área bajo esa curva vendría
siendo la distancia o la magnitud del
desplazamiento de dicho objeto que tiene
esta velocidad y que la mantenga durante
cierto tiempo en el siguiente vídeo
veremos el concepto de la velocidad
promedio ya que estamos familiarizados
con la idea de que la distancia es el
área bajo esta curva